let's see them
so good afternoon everyone
um welcome to those who are in the
chamber and also to those who are
joining us on live stream
um as always we start with apologies and
we have an apology for from Mia Clarke
who is co-chair of regional development
Forum which has been run today so he's
he's away on Council business
um so for that reason I'll be in the
chair for this meeting
um
Declarations of interest is
accepted sorry move the apology okay
um okay those in favor say aye
aye against carried
so moving to Declarations of interest
um does anybody have an interest in any
models to be discussed today that have
not already been declared Evelyn
yes I do okay so you um
do you do is your judgment do you feel
you need to retire from the chamber at
that point or will you just sit quietly
okay
I find that hard to believe but anyway
thank you
um public forum we have
um no one who has
us to speak
there is on your agenda uh major lead
item however that has been withdrawn
and will be considered at the
extraordinary council meeting which is
likely to take place next week
the next item is the hearing on fees and
charges
consultation
and we have a Rodney trade here who's
going to present to us so Rodney would
you like to come up in certain uh
chair there
and if you wish to speak for five
minutes or so then we'll ask you some
grilling questions
you have any uh cure and good afternoon
everybody
um most around the table know me for
those that don't Rodney tribe resident
and rate payer and uh some would say I'm
passionate about dogs
I'm more passionate about the putier in
my pocket to be honest
um so you would have seen my uh
submission fairly brief
um a bit of background behind that
submissions closed on the sixth I was
away on the sixth I requested
information that I got on the fourth
um so pretty much
put in a short one since then I've
received information on and off and the
last sort of information I received was
it about 6 34 last night so
okay
Council might want to tidy up its uh
information distribution processes
um so first one I'll touch on is dog
control
um obviously last year
I said that fees didn't need to rise
they were bound to rise more than they
are this year and that was held off
this year
Visa due to rise on some dogs not all
uh I still don't believe the council
should be looking at increasing fees
those that are going to be affected the
most are standard dog owners are not one
I'm a responsible dog owner so it's two
bucks to me it's nothing however
when I look at the numbers
across all the dogs at Council believes
it's got registered you're talking 20
grand
that's how much that those owners are
due to pay more than what they were last
year however dog numbers
apparently are down by 500.
it's almost 60 Grands where the dog
registrations that have disappeared out
of The Ether you only want to take 20
out of the existing owners that are
still left
huh
try and find these dogs Council hasn't
lost 592 dogs
from two years ago he had 9900 accounts
were now saying you've got 1500
8503. it's 1400 docs another cargo
hasn't lost 1400 Docs
with the amount of dogs that have been
found
uh shown online non-chipped
there's a number of dogs out there
that are actually coming back into the
population that aren't being registered
the question is why aren't they being
registered
I believe that some of these people are
struggling to pay their fees
it's the reason they'll take a gamble
won't pay a registration fee potentially
they're too high you get more dogs are
interested you can keep the cost down so
what I'm saying is next year you're
probably gonna have about 289k still
sitting in reserves after your capital
what's 301 according to the paper I got
but it should be about 289 take 20K out
of that keep your Rego fees where they
are for now and work on how you're going
to register those or get those
unregistered dogs done
especially for those that are struggling
financially
um
so that's me on dogs short this year
the next one I put in there was
water fees
um
an interesting analysis on the cost of
water
fifty three a liter a cubic meter
um dollar 44 if you take off your
exploratory trying to find another water
source from last year
however
the commercial users
between 2021 and 2022
reduce their consumption by 14 percent
council's volume awarded that they
actually treated went up
but your commercial users went down so
you've got a sector that's
trying to conserve
who's now being paid because you're
conserving you're going to pay more
because it's costing us more because
we're producing x amount and it's
costing this so when I had a look
between your commercial metered and your
tanker water users they use 31 percent
of the total water
yet from an operational cost perspective
they paid 38 of costs in the user fees
so I believe they're actually paying
enough
um I do get having watched the workshop
the other day the council might start
getting tight in terms of the rates they
take versus the actual the total amount
of Revenue hence the reason to push
user costs in certain areas up a bit
more to get that balance but
I don't think pushing water fees up
is the way to go and I'm quite adamant
on that I believe that what's being
charged at the moment is probably
sufficient the biggest cost the council
has despite me having heard that the
biggest cost of water is treatment
biggest cost of water in invercargill is
your capital expenditure on asset
renewal you can't tell me that all
contributed to by the commercial users
who are also rate payers so they're
paying rates as well so that's me on
water
uh next one and it's real brief is your
environmental health costs
so
I did query it last year
um
just had a brief look
so all your food related charges are
supposed to be based on cost recovery
um so your audits your licensing your
verification so I've asked for
where all those costs sit and I can't
get a clear breakdown if I can't get a
clear breakdown I look it and go well
how can that be based on cost recovery
it's not transparent
um alcohol licensing Falls in there as
well so it's a bit split
but
yeah to me the information I got was
feeling Bland so
I don't think oh well it's probably
going to go up but it needs to be looked
at more then I'll get into
the last one
your housing care activity
um
I do not believe
this is the time to be pushing rinse up
on those in the community who are
struggling have been struggling for
years and are probably some of the most
vulnerable
um I keep hearing we've consulted the
public
the public don't want rates going
towards it therefore it's got to be user
Pace the public haven't actually been
consulted there's been surveys run which
have
I want to put it closed questions
basically
you get the result you asked for So
within the last survey it said other
forms of funding I took that box
no one wants the rates to go up but I
says look for other forms of funding
that doesn't mean user pays
and I think I mentioned last year about
community housing providers so I know
Council are looking at building some new
units down Stewart Street great idea
brilliant stuff
I would say does council want to own
them in their own right or do they want
to own them through a community housing
provider say under ichl
um
people in those units being brand new
could in fact they won't get a
government accommodation supplement
however they'll only pay 25 of their
income and rent the government will pay
the balance
an actual fact you'll get more out of
those houses
now I know Christchurch city council put
all of these into C8 into a CHP and
under a trust they probably did it
slightly the wrong way whereas the
existing tenants were transferred with
the accommodation so they actually don't
get those subsidies they don't get
rebates but I look at and go you've got
an opportunity and I know you're going
to look at it next year or part of the
long-term plan
to actually say do we want to keep these
units as they are or do we want to build
some new units in the existing ones once
they're empty they're not housed
transfer those empty units to a
community housing provider start
refilling them and it's actually a
win-win-win except for council's balance
sheet
because with those assets sitting under
a community housing provider they might
not sit on councils and books directly
um
which was very enlightening when I saw
that
according to
the figures I was given from Council
your building valuation
there's 91.8 million bucks
that averages to four hundred and twenty
thousand dollars a unit of your current
stock
I doubt that those units are worth 91
million dollars
in actual fact QV puts them at 26 mil
and that's not
GV that's the estimated value of what
they are even if you were to take half
of that again tag it on top that's 39
mil
you've got asset valuation and there are
91 and you're depreciating it for about
a million bucks
I know that the
it's not paying that depreciation but
that depreciation's obviously sitting
somewhere oh look at that and go those
assets aren't worth it
so if those numbers don't Stack Up what
else do but again you're looking at 89
Grand
and additional rents roughly taking the
average of eight bucks
over those units
at the end of last year there were 697k
sitting in your net debt account
Ed out of that until you actually work
out what you want to do with housing
don't Ram it on the tenants yes they
might get an increase in their
accommodation supplement this year let
them have it I've already had a 30
increase I know that was uh to bring
those units up to Healthy Home standards
you've also used some three Waters
funding I think towards it so be it
but don't
put it
this will be the Socialists coming at me
don't Hammer the most vulnerable at a
time when everyone suffer
that's me
thank you
thank you Rodney as you predicted when
we spoke just before the session you
reduce the whole 10 minutes to make it
points and you have so we'll only have
one question and I'm going to allow
myself the luxury of that that that was
an extraordinary well-researched
um submission
so thank you for that my question is
have you ever thought standing for
Council
I think I did in 2016. okay
you should think about it again
thank you cheers
thank you so we have a second
um
hearing uh in this case the
um submitter will come in by telephone
and it is bridge and vidmiel cure
so if we can make contact with them then
um
[Music]
oh hello this is uh Tom Campbell here
I'm the deputy mayor and I'm chairing
the council meeting
um I believe you are you wish to make a
submission to council
um by telephone and and by the way I
should say that you're live now so
um we would very much welcome your
submission
hello
oh could you hear me at all
so this is Tom Campbell here
um I am the deputy mayor
um I know that you wish to make a
submission to Council on the telephone
so you are actually live at the moment
Council are the whole counselor here
um and we are waiting to hear your
submission if you wish to start
[Music]
for us to plan for that much
okay thank you and and I certainly
understand what you're saying
um is there anything else that you would
like to add
um
[Music]
okay
thank you is there anything else you
would like to add
okay
thank you so
um what we do at this stage is all of
the counselors are here listening to you
we ask counselors if they have any
questions
to you so I will just ask them that now
does any counselor have any question
that they wish to put
no I think we
okay speak
okay so look
um the tensless here have understood
what you have said so thank you for that
thank you for your submission
um
we we will perhaps close the call now
and thank you for that input thank you
and bye bye
okay so we also have a list of
submissions
um
from individuals who do not wish to be
heard
um do we receive the submissions that we
do okay so would anybody like to move
that we received the submissions thank
you Dan the second lead seconded by
Leslie
um any further discussion
so those in favor of that motion say I I
Against
carried thank you
so next we have the meeting of council
held on the 26th of April and the
minutes of that meeting
thank you and seconded by Darren is
there any discussion of those
councilor puttinger
thank you thank you chair look I'd like
to raise
um
an issue around item 11 and that refers
to
the the recommendation that at least 50
percent
of directors this is in the
SOI to to holco fifty percent be local
uh locally sourced now
I'm not happy with that since the 26th
of April I've read quite a few documents
including
a report commissioned by the office of
the auditor general
and when you read section 57 of the
Local Government Act this this quota
type system does not fit in to their
guidelines
um they talk about skills and other
other necessary things what I would
prefer is is Council to change its
wording to Preferred local directors and
also I don't know how you'd wear it but
somehow
um
work with the local Chamber of Commerce
which runs a a leadership courses and
that potentially is is where we could
find directors and look to but I I think
the quota and when you say 50 it is
actually because there's five directors
on eil IAL ichl you're actually talking
60 because to achieve okay cancel that I
wanted you to you know see what you had
to see and I think you made your point
yeah I mean we are receiving minutes
yeah we're not real litigating the well
original mother you know that we're
receiving the minutes
so I I think you know you've had the
opportunity to
um make those points
um but it's it's you cannot change the
minutes no no I'm not changing the
minutes what I'm trying to say is that
what we've basically done
I don't believe complies
with both the oags guidelines and the
local government act so we can receive
the minutes that's fine
but that obviously for me to challenge
this formally would be through those
process yeah yeah I I because it's my
belief and you know there's a former
chair to look some of these local
businesses that the there is nothing
about that that would conflict without
guidance
um there is nothing in that guidance
that says that you cannot
do that do a quota
that is nothing at this is that you
can't do that it's it's interpretation
the other thing I'd like to make is that
is what we have done is inconsistent
with a since recent appointment
directorship appointment to another
Council CCO where we have appointed
all of the directors outside the
district
I think that was a puppet look I I don't
want to get any real reality no no no so
so I will I think we've heard what
you've said so we will put that motion
to the floor that's being moved and
seconded
um so ask those in favor say aye aye
against
when cute so we receive those minutes
next we have the minutes of the
infrastructure committee meeting
held on the 2nd of May
and councilor potenger I'll ask if you
will move those but also
um move the proposal which is
which needs to be approved by Council
yes I will do that chair thank you
thank you is it a seconder
thanks grunt
um is there any other discussion
so those in favor say aye aye against
carried
that takes us to the minutes of the
community wellbeing committee
meeting held on the 9th of May
um and alas Darren if you will move
those next year happy to move it there
uh received thank you is it a secondary
thank you Peter is there any other
discussion
those in favor say aye aye against
carried
we then moved to the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the finance and
projects committee held on the 9th of
May
um and there is a recommendation to
council that comes from that
so Grant could ask you if you would move
both of those yes yeah I will
is there any comment you want me making
the recommendation or is it does it
stand as it is
yeah
no I think it just stands isn't as worth
it appropriately okay so we have a mover
seconded by Dan
um all those in favor say aye
aye against carried
we moved to the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the risk and
Assurance committee held on the 15th of
May
um in this case of course the chair is
now here so I will move that we received
those that seconded by councilor Soper
um is there any discussion
those in favor say I I against carried
so we now move to paper 11 which is in
iranian's name I think
I can get back to
but it should be in my papers
just noting from that chair that item
two and the recommendations has already
been done
okay
Rihanna
um thank you chair so yes this paper
speaks to the matter that the two public
hearings were related to this is fees
and charges for 20 23 24
um so this paper provides
recommendations to support your
deliberations on the fees and charges
and attaches a schedule for adoption
noting that of course it is possible to
make changes to that schedule
based on your deliberations so the paper
outlines a summary of the submissions
that have been made
um
and it includes officer recommendations
in relation to those submissions you'll
note offices are recommending three
changes to the fees and charges
scheduled as it was consulted on the
first of those is to note that we are
expecting changes on the building
control levies and that that would be
passed on to the user if and when those
are implemented it notes that following
consultation with the funeral directors
that's recommended to keep the discount
at the level at which it is but to
explore further
um what the implications would be of
bringing that service provision of
invoicing in-house and on the relation
of resource management clarifying the
nature of the deposit and that it is
refundable
um I'm happy to take any questions
thank you first one first one just from
Marianne
um the fees and charges uh that begin
the paper that begins on page 51 of
board books that's an updated paper
isn't it
the schedule itself yes the schedule
it's been updated okay thank you Alan
um yeah referring if you just get on
page 47 around and there's a piece here
about Cooper's Creek yes just wondering
if you could explain what that means
this is uh feedback is noted and no
change is required what's that mean
so um the fees and charges as relating
to Cooper's Creek note that
um they will not be implemented until
and after the ombudsman's decision is
reached
um there were a number of communications
from Coopers Creek's residents that they
did not went made as formal submissions
but have been provided to councilors to
review so it's just noting that we all
recognize the process that's ongoing
any other questions ringing yeah thank
you champ Ariana mine's around dog fees
now the um the calculation of dog fees
and and this is sort of I'm asking
how it's done do we work out the cost of
running the dog control service and then
do we divide it or is there a certain
amount of public good on from other rate
players paying for the dog control
Service as well I'm just looking at how
we come how we work out our dog fees
because I'm just looking at Palmerston
North's dog fees and they are twice
twice as so I'm just wondering does it
cost more to run it or or uh how it
works you know how we come to that
number
so the fees are set in line with the
revenue and finance policy and what that
sets in terms of the breakdown of how we
fund each service including the dog as
part of the regulatory activity and then
the team Works to review what their
costs are in delivering the service and
then calculate the actual fee and so
that's the process that it's gone
through
um
more specific feedback I would need to
direct so could I say it's not a hundred
percent funded I'd say might be 60
funded from dog fees and 40 from other
rates or Patricia's looking interested
I'm just going to direct that to
the gym of Finance Insurance because I
don't have the revenue and finance
policy in front of me
um so dog fees form part of their Animal
Control activity
um and in the last ltp it was
um indicated that there was to be some
benefit from rights to that activity
it's approximately around the 15 15
funded by rates right
um and then the balance is funded by
Facebook no no that's fine I just trying
to work out why our fees uh are so low
compared to other Council so no no
that's okay thank you thank you so
darling then Grant
thank you my question somebody might be
able to help me isn't around housing
care and I was just wanting to
understand the accommodation supplement
that people are paid is that a full sum
or is it proportionate to whatever uh
the rental
they are paying is so in other words do
they get say fifty dollars and if if the
uh their accommodation is less than that
they keep the difference or is it only
paid out based on what their rental is
so I have colleagues here from the
housing team if I could invite them to
come forward to answer that question
through cheer
um I have with me Deborah who as their
housing officer who has also quite a
comprehensive understanding of how the
accommodation supplement works
um so it might be best if Deborah was to
explain how so it is based on
um the level of rental
and
um the asset level as well and any other
income level that they may have
so there is a threshold for the cutoff
for the level of rental
and then that is determined on what
their income is how much assets they
have and what proportion of the
accommodation supplement they are
eligible for
so they're not paid above what their
rental would be no no no I think the
concern that was expressed by councilors
when we talked about this at the
workshop was an understanding of even
although the increase was relatively
modest if I remember it's 189 or
something like that but it's a smaller
moon but actually quite a lot to some of
the individuals concerned so the
discussion was about whether the housing
supplement would pay would be likely pay
some or all of that
and I think the answer was well it
depends on the circumstances there was
no single yes or no answer
but I I think counselors would be
interested in
um perhaps a little bit more a little
bit Fuller explanation than that I mean
put simply well most people
will the 89 extra they have to pay is
that likely to be
um paid as a housing supplement
I can't answer that for all of the
tenants because it does depend on search
um there has been an increase to the
um
to the to the supplement level to the
level where they're eligible to apply
for rental
um there hasn't been an increase to the
amount of supplement in invercargill
um but it increases the eligibility
range
so some tenants who may not have been
eligible before may now be eligible
under that criteria
um if we increase our rental
you were going to ask a question
specifically in this matter aren't you I
I was actually just going to ask
and have some more details I was just
going to ask before we get any deeper
into the conversation of preps Deborah
could
come on
so
the great majority of our tenants
because of their circumstances probably
are eligible for the accommodation
supplement
the threshold currently
um as of the 1st of April of this year
is 124 so any rental above that then
gets the calculation done on it to give
them their accommodation supplement
portion that they get
so as the rent goes up and it's more
above that 124 dollars
therefore they can get more
accommodation supplement
so that's how how it works sort of
Simply if that makes sense
um it's only based on 70 cents and the
dollar so 70 is the maximum but the
difference between the 124 and what they
pay so if that's another twenty dollars
that's then calculated by 70 cents and
that's how the accommodation supplement
amount is worked out and that's what
they then receive per week so if I can
I'm probably misunderstanding that but
what I think I heard you see is that
um if the extra rent was ten dollars
just to make the sums easier if the
extra rent was ten dollars then they
would probably have to pay three
themselves because it was only 70
percent that would be subsidized okay
thank you just as a supplement well
could I
just asked deeper and Heather to remind
us about the asset level
um that is
part of the criteria for the occupants
of our units I think that'd be useful
information to for councilors to
understand so as far as I'm
understand
8100 is the asset level
um I believe that's like a cashier said
I don't know the full way that they
assess that but that 8100 is the
threshold limit so that they can have up
to that amount and then still receive
the accommodation supplement if they
have more than that say for example they
have 10 000 then they wouldn't receive
that supplement yeah and that is why
you've told us that the majority of our
tenants we yeah we understand are
eligible for the accommodation
supplement because we have a criteria on
asset levels before they become our
tenants we do and a great deal of the
tenants
um or the and even the people that apply
quite often don't have anything at all
so you know obviously those ones do now
um yeah that's
thank you yeah so uh look at I think
that it's very important that councilors
do you understand the session therefore
you know thank you for coming and
explaining it to us
um
dude Trish is your question about
housing yes
okay so can I keep pushing Grant back
but I'm assuming yours is not about
who's in Christ thank you for your chair
so do all the people who are eligible
for the supplement do they all access it
and are they given any support to accept
of the great majority they do
um when we did the big increases a
couple of years back
we made sure that when we sent out the
information to them that they got an
accommodation supplement form and also a
reply paid envelope so that that could
go back to work and income so that made
it easy for them and I did assist some
of them I still have a some that are of
the mine they've sort of old school
mindset but I've managed to change a
couple of those over the last year
um and just if I'm aware and I I get to
know them quite well because I see them
every six months um
I get to to know and if I feel that I
can sort of encourage them even though
they feel you know I'm not going to take
anything because I'm responsible for
myself if they have that attitude I just
try and work with them and just say well
hey look you know you've contributed all
your life you know you're entitled to
this
do take it please do take it and
sometimes I have to help them with the
forms and and facilitate it and assist
that but
um yeah as I said I've converted a few
of them so I I try and give them that
continual ongoing support and if they
say they're struggling I always make
sure are you getting the accommodation
supplement you know it's worth you
seeing if you are entitled for it and
yeah just try and encourage them as much
as possible but some of them are a wee
bit storage thank you appreciate that so
I think we may end the housing
discussion at that point
um I think you can safely assume that
you'll get cross-examined again next
year so you know you know the kind of
questions that we're going to ask you so
I think you know any additional
information you can provide us I mean
counselors are mainly concerned that we
don't push people into
um you know real hardship as a
consequence of very small numbers of
dollars which no matter how fair it
might seem it may not seem fair if
you're in the other side of their career
Asian and you're struggling for every
dollar so you know please keep us you
know please inform us on that next year
so thank you very much for that and then
thank you so Grant
yes and my question thanks to you is
with respect to the funeral directors
discount and the recommendation to not
charge that so
there's a comment a large impact on
already tight margins is that the
funeral directors margins correct so how
did we establish their topic margins
that is the feedback being provided so
they told us they had taught me correct
okay it's interesting
um then the eight percent what does that
actually turn into in a monetized amount
[Music]
no I see that but in terms of what's the
cost that they
they are receiving a benefit of in terms
of monetary terms I think it is um
it is one hundred thousand dollars
across all of the funeral directors no
but each individual cremation or plot I
can't give you that information I don't
know that information but it's going to
depend on each service that they've
received
oh
because yeah I I just don't see the
commercial
um
objection is real
to us putting up those fees chair I see
that the GM of finance and Assurance
might be able to give some information
on the average
not can't quite do the average uh three
years chair um there is approximately
500 burials and cremations happening in
the city so that hundred thousand
divided by 500 would give you a very
rough
um one just by the number 200 per
commission but it's a chromatic there's
different costs you know because it's a
discount and a percentage discount but
it gives you Alan is your question the
same subject that's about the same thing
actually yeah
from what I'm understanding
I they're actually basically doing a job
for us I think so in fact if they didn't
get their discount and do that invoicing
job
do it in fact have three somebody here
that did their job so in any future
the discount you could say could
possibly go on a salary or something if
but it was dropped all right let's
assuming that so yes counselor through
UK you are correct
um the feedback from the funeral
directors is that the families
appreciate having one invoice and
essentially they are this is the
feedback from the funeral directors that
as part of that process then they are
carrying the risk of non-payment
um we certainly could and that's why the
recommendation is worded the way that it
is look at investigating further what it
would mean to provide the service
in-house and that is something that we
recommend doing through the engagement
with the funeral directors
um the question that councilors had
earlier about whether that discount was
being passed on to the families it is
not being passed on it is being
perceived by the funeral directors as a
cost of business so it's certainly
something that officers would recommend
looking at the pros and cons
of implementing it in a different way
going forward
so obviously you know the the
cost which is avoided by Funeral
Directors is passed on to ratepayers
through the race so obviously it doesn't
just vanish so
um Grant are you
um of a view since you've raised the
mother that we should move to change
that I mean I guess there are three
options one is we accept officers
recommendations a second is that we go
with original proposal I suppose it's a
third does that we do a step off
so you could go with a four percent
discount for example and then step Duty
zero you know really signaling the tent
that we stepped in easier next year
um
Steve I I know that you've been involved
in this signaled it as an option could
we do the stepped approach because we
never signaled it okay I'm not sure
so there's a question as to process the
yes we have consulted on the eight
percent and there's zero percent which
is what we consulted on
um so whether we could go to four
percent
the sense better than eight it's
difficult to see who would oppose it
but I mean you know if we're not allowed
to do it then we're not allowed to do it
there's some hands meant up in a
mythology you first in Alex
thank you Mr chair I absolutely
understand
um your suggestion of the four percent
stepped approach however that doesn't
actually change anything for where their
activity sits for the funeral director
or for us ourselves
um and a few of them have indicated in
their submissions that uh if if they we
were to increase the price at all that
they would effectively kick it to us and
say sorry you'll have two invoices and
so we would immediately and house have
to pick up that resource so um I would
be of my mind to continue pursuing with
the recommendation and that we don't
rise at that eight percent but perhaps
look at and quantify what that resource
cost would be for us to bring it
in-house for our next round of fees of
charges
so Evelyn
Mr chair um I think the thing for me is
that
it's not only that we would have to do
the work we would be carrying the debt
and I think this is what the funeral
directors are drawing to your attention
that eight percent discount that they
receive
they carry the debts for however long it
takes to be reimbursed for the services
they provide and whilst in an Ideal
World we would think that everybody
would have that amount available the
reality is many of perhaps most do not
so for X number of months they carry
forward including the cost of our
services on their box so if we're asking
them to do that
do we want to take that liability we
already know how difficult it can be to
recover fees incurred for our Direct
Services that we charge this is
something that we would be taking on
board it's a cost to us whichever way
you look at it is the eight percent
costs to us for re you know re
um the discount
lesser or greater than we would
incur ourselves by by charging and
trying to recover well certainly it's
interest rates go up you have to see
that the two numbers are probably
getting pretty close with me but darling
you
next year I'm playing devil's advocate
here
in the in the submissions from the
funeral directors they've said well we
they could kick it back to us
and and we double invoice them and they
currently feedback that for their
customers that is a convenience if they
only have to pay the one invoice well
ultimately that becomes a business
decision for them
if they want to carve out a point of
difference
over their competitor it would be that
we'll only make sure you've got the one
invoice
so that's a business decision that that
they can make again just putting I don't
necessarily like it being how low for us
as a as a threat alternatively it's a
business
um point of difference that they're able
to take up if they chose to okay
Okay so
Leslie you've been waiting thank you Mr
chair
um
having asked for the consultation
feedback
and got it
um it seems to me that the you know
we've identified while your idea of the
four percent was
quite a novel one that that it's not
workable we consulted on eight percent
or nothing having got in good faith the
feedback
um I'm tending to think that holding the
eight percent in place for the year
while we do the full review as
highlighted in the recommendation is
actually the sensible way to to progress
it
um we do need to look at the cost of
council invoicing if that's what we
decide is is what we do we haven't
looked in depth at that it's been raised
as part of the consultation that was
there's a
administrative difficulty there
um
for the relatively small
um 0.15 percent
um
for the next year I actually think
there's a lot of sense in saying let's
do the review and actually map out what
it means
so I think the look the default position
I think that is that we would accept
um officers recommendations unless there
was a strong view around the table that
we should not
um that are that are certainly of you
among some counselors that that we
should not
um I get the impression grant that
probably in a minority
um happy to be yeah so so uh what I
would suggest is that
um that we do ask officers next year to
bring back our you know a a balance of
this is what would cost Council if we
were to take it in-house
um so that we can better understand
where the balance sits
um and I think that would be very useful
when we consider this session next year
you'll give it background
um yeah look I'm happy oh I don't agree
but I'll go with it but I think you know
there's a couple of things you need to
think about you could send them one
invoice a year
you don't have to send them 500 invoices
no but Christmas blue we would cut it
the debt for a year then wouldn't we
yeah well we have not carrying the deal
we're just recovering it we're not
carrying it we're just recovering it
more in Campbell is still thought going
interest on them yeah
yeah
okay okay so look again I I unless you
wish to move that we reverse that
recommendation okay so are there any
other questions to Rihanna
no okay so in that case
um we have uh number of recommendations
which are probably shown on the board
behind me
um I don't think there's any need to
take them individually
um so will somebody move that we
do all of those things receive and Note
and adopt
um as listed there so I'll move that
with the exception of item two which
we've already done
okay thank you is there any other
discussion
so those in favor say aye aye against
cut it thank you
so Rihanna and you are up again I think
thank you chair so this um next paper
relates to preparation for the long-term
plan and specifically the element
related to the Strategic projects so
outlines a number of recommendations
sorry if I can just
interrupt you while I actually find it
my apology so I managed to lose my place
okay
okay page 117 of board books for anybody
who's like me
so Rhiannon
um this paper
I guess summarizes the discussion that
was held on the 26th of April
um by Council on this model of strategic
projects and we I guess Traverse it for
several years didn't we so I don't think
there's a need to go through them in
detail but what I will ask you to do
before we take questions is there
anything in this paper which materially
differs from what was
agreed and formally by Council on the
26th of April
no
okay so are there any questions of
Rihanna
and if not will somebody move that we do
all of the things that are you know Mr T
I just need a point of clarification
right um I think Andrew has identified
that 9B refers to ICL I think that
should be hwcp
so it's just a correction to the okay
point there
so with that correction
um we are asked to
do 10 things receive note adopt note
note
they're over the page ah okay so we are
asked to
approve
or know many things
is there any
if there are no further questions will
soon be removed that we do all of those
things okay thanks Dan the sort of
secondary things
thanks buddy
um is there any further discussion
and if not
um we'll move the resolution
uh those in favor say aye
aye against carried thank you
um
so
the next paper
is again in your name Rihanna and it's
housing an approach for directing
disposal of land and property
um in that case we had a long-term plan
workshop on the 18th of April on housing
um we had another one on the 16th of May
on the issue of disposal of land
um and we spent you know a day and a
half really talking about these models
so we won't repeat that now but can ask
you the question I asked you in the last
paper is there anything in this paper in
the recommendations that materially
differs from what council and formally
agreed at the workshops
no
okay so questions to Rihanna
and there are no questions and
sorry Evelyn have you got a question
um it's a little bit difficult
yeah
talking thing in this you mean the
disposal the housing paper and the
disposal of line paper yeah and
I guess that what I'm struggling with a
little bit is
how we make those things talk to each
other so Council doesn't have a huge
amount of surplus land we may think we
do but in actual fact there's lots of
reasons why we want green space and all
those sorts of things so the thing for
me and all of this is that then
is there a suggestion as part of the
solution that we become
a purchaser of properties that could be
developed as opposed to currently vacant
Lots
to better utilize some of the spaces
that are perceived to exist and is that
really the role that we should do but it
is a question that has been coming to my
mind quite a lot because
how do we
effectively
create
the space and utilize it best and is
that something that the that the private
Market is going to do when what we're
talking about is potentially housing
densification or things like that
and it's not that I think we can resolve
it today but
this is what this has brought to my mind
if we want more houses but we don't want
to use up our Green Space or even our
Brownfield space how do we do that and
is that the more effective use of the of
the the housing stock and the buildings
that we have now because we know that
we've got a lot of buildings set
or are perhaps not as fit for purpose as
they could be but we don't have the
power to do anything about it
um so I I don't mean to be an agitator
or anything like that but I do want to
plant the seed that we may have to
actually make some sort of
um fairly assertive decisions in the
future to acquire
the space to be able to intensify to
find ways of encouraging others to find
ways of encouraging out there because I
agree with you 100 I think that we
um but we must not allow to happen as a
progressively aging and crumbling
Central City where we just keep filling
getting built let's see that that that's
not what we want to do and and I think
the end up in this paper
um where we talk about you know the
possibility of releasing some land for
housing
um I'm not I'm not sure if you were at
that meeting actually but if you the the
land that we were looking at and were
shown and discussed
um most of it was within the city so but
but no but also I would agree with the
point that we should not roll out the
possibility of buying land
um where it makes more sense than just
to have it crumble around us you know
Leslie you you were going to ask a
question thanks Mr chair it's not so
much a question it's just to lead on
from what Evelyn has said and what
you've just said I felt that um
recommendation nine and recommendation
11 in particular
um did
the two things coming together so nine
is saying that Council would consider
potential Partnerships
yeah now that doesn't fit leave the
scope that part of that potential
partnership might be an exchange of land
or Council
investing in a parcel of land as part of
a partnership it's it's leaving it
enough as a general recommendation and
principle to cover several potential
ways a partnership might come together
and 11
um which we had had talked about quite
thoroughly and you're referred to as
whether we do have our own land and or
Property Holdings that may play a role
either through reclassification or
disposal
um
and yes I think you've just indicated we
have already started looking at at the
strong possibility that we do have some
of those and that we could take action
on them
um
and I'm sure Evelyn is quite quite right
to bring up the question of reserve and
in Green Space and so forth but I think
again 11 seemed to me written in a way
that allows us to look at possible use
of our own land or property
without that needing to encroach on
green on important Green Space well well
fundamentally I think when it comes to
land in particular it is Outland
we're making no more of it God's making
no more of it so
um we should try to protect what we have
and and I think that you know underlying
principle
um as actually was trying to be captured
in this paper so I think you know we
keep making sure that that's the
um the approach that we take
so any other questions
yeah just uh thanks
through the discussions in the workshops
it consistently came up around we need
to get some action and some momentum
around actually delivering so
um you know be good to understand you
know what the process looks like from
here like when when will we be looking
to form strategic Partnerships when
we'll be looking to change land use you
know and some of the sort of bigger
sections around that maybe could do with
sort of a revamp those sorts of things
when when are we actually going to see
some action around housing to start
providing what we're talking about in
these papers yeah yeah I'm not saying
and I think it comes to also the role
and just been rather than just speaking
about being prepared to consider these
things they were actually in the front
for looking for the opportunities aren't
we and and you know inviting people and
you talk to us about what may be done
and that is a really similar stuff
happening as you as you no gun but I
think going forward
um we would be Keen to be involved in in
that so other questions
of Rihanna
okay so we have a number of
recommendations
um none of the questions I've had I
think would change any of them but we
maybe emphasize
that we would emphasize but we'd maybe
just particularly know number nine in
the importance of that
um
well somebody moved that we
agree with all of those thank you Leslie
this is second in the rear is there any
other discussion
all those in favor say aye aye against
carried thank you
so
the next one is also in your name
it's me again
so
this one is about the appointments of a
committee for the connected
joint committee and factors for an
appointments committee isn't it
yeah
um so I'll speak very briefly to this
paper
um just to provide a bit of background
and an update so at the beginning of
last year as part of the just
transitions process
um one of the seven work streams was
supported through invercargill city
council it was a regional work stream it
was intended to look at specifically how
should the community be supported
through the potential closure of Ty or
any other economic shock the other six
work streams were focused primarily on
economic aspects so it was felt was
really important that the community was
represented so the project proposal that
was put together
um resulted after a intensive Community
engagement period over the first half of
last year it was steered by a working
group that included representatives from
menofenowa and from the three councils
across South America as well as various
Community Representatives who are active
in the community development space it's
about the proposal itself speaks to the
things that the community said they felt
were really needed in order to improve
connections and resilience
which was around supporting those
Community leaders who are on the coal
face as it were so those Mobi
individuals working with specific
Community groups or individuals working
with agencies that deliver social
services so that's the background for
why the project has been designed in the
way that it was one of the things that
was really important to the community
was that the project B Community LED and
be able to evolve over time and that
therefore the governance structure that
would be set up would be able to support
that
the Merrell Forum considered the
question of the governance structure
last year prior to the election they had
five different options put to them as to
what could be a potential approach for a
governance structure and their preferred
approach was a joint committee which
would be made up not only of council but
of monofinoa Representatives and direct
Community representation from people
working in the sector it's intended to
be a transitional Arrangement so that
over time the best structure that the
community feels is the right structure
going forward can be put in place so
that's the reason for the 18-month
period it's not intended to be a
long-term structure unless that's what
the community feels is needed
um probably the challenge that's going
to be there going forward is how to get
a group that's going to support this
project get off the ground has the
skills necessary while providing
representation across the very broad
range of interests that are involved so
um that's the background to the process
the role of the appointments committee
is to support the Joint Committee coming
into the fore and specifically to select
the appropriate Community
Representatives which would be invited
to apply through an open advertising
campaign
if how many start with the first
question Rhiannon
um all this was discussed by the mutual
Forum quite a long time ago
um nearly the whole mutal Forum has
changed I certainly detect uh different
mid respect to creating yet more joint
committees
I observe if I've got this correct that
we're talking about a governance group
of a reasonably significant number of
people with one employee
is that right correct right one employee
and the role of that employee will be to
tie together the various Community
threads that are running and I think
it's well worth where I work
my question and I don't know maybe
you're late but my question would be why
you would not simply fund it through
Great South
I know it's not only your decision but I
just wonder if you'd like to respond to
that rather than create another you know
eight or ten people or something that is
a governance group
so that was certainly one of the options
that was considered at that time of the
Merrell Forum previously
um the
I can't speak exactly to the decision
that was made around that but certainly
the background and the discussion was
around the role of Great South in
Economic Development not in supporting
Community engagement and not wanting
this to weaken their focus on what the
Merrell Forum wanted them to be focused
on which is driving economic growth in
the region so that was certainly what
was one of the things that was discussed
around that question specifically
speaking to the question of it being
quite a rigorous kind of governance
structure for what is in the first
instance quite a small project I think
that certainly
correct however one of the big drivers
in this was balancing up the concerns of
the community for being able to
influence representation which they are
able to do through a joint community
community community joint committee
structure with the needs of the funder
MB which requires a certain level of
governance and so this was the structure
that they have agreed to fund under and
that the enduring oversight group has a
group so just to be clear
um are you seeing that this whole
project will be funded by MB
the funding to seed fund as it were the
project will be funded by MB and the one
of the roles of the coordinator will be
to seek further funding
um what does seed funding mean rhiannons
I mean her salary or her salary will be
paid for a year or three years or what
does it mean covers the costs for the
first 18 months of the project and
should know further funding be achieved
then the project would be able to be
wound up then with some website
resources and best practice being
developed but it certainly is the role
of that person to seek further funding
from many different alternate sources do
we know whether any of the
other councils have actually nominated
people for to be on that appointments
panel so we've had initial conversations
with the governance managers at both
Southern District Council and Gore
District Council and it is on the agenda
for those councils for I think the first
and the 13th of June but I could have
got those exact dates not quite correct
we are first yeah I'm going to open it
for about questions but discussion I
think I mean it seems a giant slow
charity crack a nut
um when you have you know maybe eight or
ten or so of a governance group who are
managing and governing activities of one
person whose funding will only last for
18 months and then inevitably they'll
look to councils to
fund beyond that
um nature of the project is such that
it's not a job in Finnish after 18
months there is no way if you look at it
they're going to set up systems that tie
together groups and it's going to have a
ongoing
um should have actually some ongoing uh
work but um
look could I open it to others to
questions uh
um Andrew I understand that
um the funding is for 18 months and part
of that role is for the person in the
role to get more funding correct so in a
feat she's she hate the person is
looking to have funding to continue her
role
to continue the work of the of the
project yes so if there's no
I'm sorry what I'm trying to understand
is
why
would the project stop
uh exactly there's no reason why it
would stop I'm just saying accepting the
circumstances where no further funding
yeah was achieved but that person would
have a personal initiative
to find the funding because it would
have pay her salary pay the job
well one would hope that that person
would also be motivated by the benefits
to the community as well yeah bottom
line is it yes thank you
are those questions
thank you Mr chair um I think this is a
really exemplary case of don't look a
gift horse in the mouth
um and then I don't know what the rest
of the proverbial is kick it somewhere
you don't want it to be
um
Envy is looking to give us and other
councils money to further a piece of
work that's actually really quite
integral for our communities it's
bringing together those pieces that
quite often don't typically get a lot of
attention
um there's been cases where we've worked
really well with our other Regional
counterparts and there's been some real
success stories out of that
um I would really hesitate for us to to
remove ourselves from this piece
okay
I mean I guess
there's no other questions I think but I
I guess my
view would be that
um
it's got some leg free money
so
um the opportunity to get 18 months of
money from MB to support the start up
here this I think you know we wouldn't
we should not look at gift to us in the
mouse so I agree with that
um I I do Wonder though whether at the
end of that 18 months when inevitably I
think he or she will come to councils
for funding it continue with the role
and by the way come in a just
Transitions and Beyond 2025 there's many
things like this in there right there
are many people without funding for the
rules so this is just one of them
um that maybe the end of 18 months we
would be encouraging an approach of
takina under Great South you still get
you pay a salary understand that but you
don't have all the governance additional
governance cost but in the meantime
um we are asked to nominate
to people to be on an appointment panel
um I would propose that one of those
should be from the monofino
representatives and the other one should
be from the broader Council
um I wonder whether
anybody wishes to
Allah first both of you are noting so
who's
panya okay
um is it a volunteer amongst the um
amongst the rest of council
could I ask councilor Cricket if she's
interested
yep
and you're looking at me because she was
resolutely not looking at me as I said
but
yep okay
so I appreciate that so appreciate those
volunteers
um so Pony and Alex will select the um
members of that committee I will be a
nominees well no we appoint them don't
we so
um we'll be appointed to the
appointments committee
and um you know I guess we take it from
there I guess from the chair I would
encourage though as discussions moving
forward along the lines of you know let
us know have a totally separate
governance arrangement for only one
person gonna go ahead in that Alan
number five says that we've still got
we're not still not going to move that
either does or does not seek
representation don't we I mean it's
probably if you ever see that probably
think it's oh we do I don't think we
need to check it either at the moment do
we I think we can leave number five on
the table
number five on the list
we don't then we don't need any
Representatives do we well we we need
Representatives on the appointments
committee
I don't think but Rihanna's going to
correct me I don't think we really need
to nominate people to be in the Joint
Committee at this stage I mean that
should be a matter of volunteers and you
know maybe there's five Volunteers in
the between panya and Alex you have to
choose
you don't have to do that now but it
would mean another paper coming back at
a later point so it's really whether you
want to discuss the matter again uh
because that we would need a formal
delegate so it's really up to it's up to
cancer whether they want to discuss that
now or later I would like to have Alex
and Pioneer get a fuel for the whole
thing so that when a new pen and paper
is brought back we can be informed about
how the whole thing's shaping up
so let's let's leave that number five
aside and we will come back to it not
only a matter of kicking it down the
road it's the fact that there's no it
may be better to do it sequentially I
think
okay
thank you so we have um four remaining
uh
for approval
um we'll summon move all four of those
you're my default person done and so I
was looking here thank you we'll summon
second thanks so much Trish
um is there any other discussion yes Mr
chair I'm sorry I'm just thinking about
the leaving off of five
I'm not sure how easy it's going to be
for our two appointees to be appointed
to an appointments committee
for connected mirohaku Joint Committee
without dealing with number five in some
form
I I think that we should say I think we
could certainly see it does seek
representation on The Joint Committee I
think I believe the nomination without
mentality yeah that's what that's what
I'm tending to think maybe the uh a
suggestion that we could go as far as to
confirm
the dad's secret presentation I thought
it was going to be a joint committee
we're going to be part of it so I think
it would be good to at least have that
there
Okay so
and reserves the right to yeah and
reserves the right to nominate name the
person later or something like that yeah
[Music]
just just to explain I think that then
leaves us with the ability to discuss
with the other two councils when they've
made their decisions whether all three
of us have
and perhaps want to come back to the
councils I just think it would be good
to have at least something in there to
indicate yeah no I agree with you that's
a good point and I think also
um it will be a matter
again of the these appointments will be
okay we always want volunteers but
effectively it tends to be the mayor
that points to join committees um we
will have by that team you'll have a new
counselor
um through the election period that
allows Nobby I think to look at the
makeup of different committees and try
to balance it out
so I I think it's better to kick that
party in the road
okay so we put what did we get to we
want to move on secondary oh how are we
oh second I think Darren Darren moved
sorry I have to make sure they're happy
with the change you're happy with the
change ecstatic okay is there any
further discussion if not
um I'll put the resolutions those in
favor say aye
aye against
correct thank you
thank you
so the next paper
um we have is the draft statement of
intent but in fact that paper has been
withdrawn by slaf today so we'll bring
that one back
um is that likely to come back to the
extraordinary meeting next week or is it
a longer
so it's so I can add to that it's option
for
possible for next week but I believe
it's more likely to be the June meeting
is there any issues arise from
that level
um it makes me very happy that it's been
withdrawn because I was challenged with
some of the wording in it and I was
wondering how I was going to sit on my
hands and keep my mouth shut so that was
that was a matter for you declare it is
never my declared interest so
um just because I
um which I have
briefly touched on with the CE this
morning because of some of the language
wording in it
um but I don't see for the board any
issue the more it's in a show for if
council is challenged by the Auditors
for the fact that we have not done this
the fact that it's going to be
unnecessary after the after we have our
first board meeting as as right the
issue really so that's fine so we um
we'll come back to that another time
I look
um just curious and mentions and and
section 3.2 of what people sorry out of
the draft statement of intent I'm just
it mentions about an interim board
creating the esoi
when it comes back obviously a month
away will we have the new board
announced obviously
um don't believe it announced I mean
obviously you sleep anymore and I'm
asking but they won't be in office by
that stage okay and then the selection
process can I ask since I brought it up
in the minutes earlier are we going for
a selection process that has 50 local
limits okay yes yes of the new board yes
the the only thing I would say in that I
mean I think it's a practical reality
that we ought to actually try and
attract Southland based members but of
course that resolution is I understand
it applied to hawk or Not Apply I don't
think so I thought it applied to ccos
yeah I applied to ccos I don't think
well why don't you be corrected but yeah
back to all ccos yeah ccos yeah so we
can expect when we see the board that 60
or 50 will be
um I can local so the counter has
already seen the proposed incoming board
and it has been
and while the council doesn't approve it
you are aware of who they all are yeah
and that is of course still in public
excluded at the moment while the final
stages of that are done so I won't
choose to elaborate any further no no no
but we would assume they're yeah
and there is a plan on how to address
the 50 ratio yeah there is yeah can I
just say I'm I'm a little bit nervous
about
straying into discussing a paper that
we've actually withdrawn from the agenda
any further and I just wonder if the
conversation needs to be closed sure I
mean I will if Michael wants to say
something on there um mine's not
directly in relation to the paper it's
about the question in relation to the 50
uh shareholding
um no no 30 directors uh 50 director
sorry my apology
um uh this is only a CCO during why
we've got the appointees but in this
particular
um entity uh once it doesn't
um
moves on to the next stage it's no
longer a CCO and doesn't come under that
remit of 50
regardless of that I would like clarify
that it has been the board's intent the
whole way along to try and Achieve that
that ratio but it will not be a CCO
won't fall in into that requirement
going forward but it will still need an
SOI even though it's not a not going
forward this is not going for just
currently so without clarification I
think you know particularly is the
suggestion that we move on
um Grant I think you put your hand up
but it was it the same subject yeah so I
think we I think we do move on so that
papers
um withdrawn the next paper is the
one-headed amendment to governance
statement an essentially this is your
name make a list is essentially a Teddy
or peasant of all of the changes that
we've made in the last few months yes
yeah thank you Mr chair that is
absolutely correct
um I think it's probably easier for me
to stay here rather than trying to run
down there all the time
but yes in this sense it's just tidying
up some recent changes and we've also
taken the opportunity to update the name
of the chief executive uh
too much else I need to say there other
than we have identified that there is a
conflict for councilor dermity and his
new role as portfolio lead for the
museum because he is also the chair of
the finance and projects committee that
is charged with having oversight of that
specific project it's not insurmountable
the suggestion would be that uh
councilor Campbell you cheer there's at
those aspects of the finance and
projects um committee meeting so it's a
it's an easy solution but it's one that
we do need to thank you Raising Flag do
I get more money
is the deputy Deputy here yes so this is
a very elegant solution yeah you could
even say was designed for such occasions
yeah
so do you need to say anything else no
are there any questions of Michael
foreign
under my committee the infrastructure
committee I see the and deletion of
councilor scalp but it still States 11
members
um
and that we now have 10 members so can
we just get there
thanks good good spotting thank you
thank you and unless we're going to
appoint another member well potentially
with a new councilor after the
by-election but we can change it then oh
okay so yeah but in the meantime the
paper should reflect the correct number
so the papers should change to 10 right
thank you okay if there are no other
questions of Michael then we will move
to the recommendations
um that we received the report that we
note the changes and then we adopt the
new governance statement which has
changed in accordance with the with
number two
let's see in the appendix
um will someone move that thank you
Leslie and seconded by Buddy
um is it any other discussion
those in favor say aye aye against
carried
thank you
so the next paper
is the proposed
remit to the local government annual
general meeting
um which I believe
has to be approved within seven days or
something is that great Michael because
uh yeah let's get a very short
um thank you thank you Mr chair I will
very briefly introduce this from the
procedural aspects and then I will hand
it over to our councilor Cricket
um so in order to make the remits for
the local government New Zealand annual
general meeting uh the remit is due to
be submitted by end of day tomorrow so
there is a reasonably tight turnaround
if this Council wishes to endorse it I
understand
um from the paper so for those of you
who haven't realized there is the remit
has been changed and that is now the
paper copy in front of you it has been
updated on board box but only if you've
resynced your device since
um about 2 30 this afternoon
um so
we've got um
a couple of things that would need to
happen for Council to be able to endorse
it along with the young elected members
but I don't believe that if Council if
Council chooses not to endure certainly
is it simply to the young electeds that
will still be submitted
um
and but I would probably make the one
suggestion that the italics piece there
probably should come out I think there
was just as a as a guide and working
comment rather than actually something
that probably should go through to the
room in context that's it thinking
recent examples yeah it was probably
more of a um working commentary
perhaps
um outside of that I will um very
happily hand over to uh councilor
cricket
um thank you Mr Morris
um the additions um that went in was
just an additional paragraph around
um contextually why young elected
members Network and committee believes
that it should certain local government
New Zealand so this was advice that um
and it's the the fourth paragraph and
the rematch from the top
um this was in consultation with local
government New Zealand themselves as
well so and as well as our Network and
as well as National Council so they've
all fed in National Council was really
really receptive we had fantastic
feedback around the table at National
Council on Friday from Mayors and chairs
congratulating the young elected members
for being the ones to Champion the sport
so that's really supportive
um
yeah I guess there's it's a lot there's
a lot to say and there's a lot to say in
this remit but I think our Council being
the one that recognizing that obviously
issues do arise we've seen them before
in our recent history but just I'm
really proud of us for even having this
on the table to support this discussion
in advance of the AGM I think it's
really clear that invercargill city
council that we're all committed to
helping assist the entire national
network raise standards of behavior not
it's not just a reflection on us or
historical items it's actually
protecting and safeguarding young
elective members and all elected members
across the network for future purpose
um
I think some key things that come around
uh
that feed into it I suppose is that the
ability to triage issues some complaints
and concerns as they arise as key quite
often there's things that do arise that
don't really have a place to go or don't
really have a safe route if there's um
investigation into a into a process or a
triage system that sits with local
government New Zealand really rise the
possibility of people having a safe
Avenue to bring those forward
we also believe that there needs to be a
really proportionate flexible system
with tiered escalation that meets the
needs of any issue as it arises
um
members currently aren't protected
through confidentiality so often those
small issues that we've spoken about or
that I've mentioned are left being
unaddressed and that member potentially
feeling unsafe to come forward
local government New Zealand becomes
aware of issues at the moment only
really when they escalate out of the
point of control we've seen that very
recently just up the road here from our
neighbors and that actually ends up
discrediting local democracy as a whole
so having this triage system here that
can intercept some of these things
before they get escalate to that point I
think will really benefit local
democracy across the motto
um I think I'll leave it there because I
could probably talk about this for a
couple of hours if you let me but I'd
welcome any questions
um look my question is around
um I'll just get a paper it's under
background and context and
uh third paragraph it's the last one and
ends
an inverted comments comma's wit bus
ticket now where what what is proposed
like I've read through it and I I can't
see anything suggested to a place the
so-called whip bus ticket because
obviously I'll look through the
schedule seven of the Local Government
Act and
ousting of a member or censorship
uh and sections one and two was quite
brutal and requires uh either you know
certain criminal activities and and
um
not being able to perform so what is
proposed because obviously if we if you
do all the hard work at the start
where does this finally end up
[Applause]
um and trying to deliver something
better than a wet bus ticket so I think
you can answer if you wish I was going
to say it could it's almost rhetorical
because the reality as a whole thing is
it's asking the question rather than
trying to answer it so I I don't know is
it realistic if you the reason I asking
and the reason I'm asking is that if you
call the existing punishments or or or
things that uh that are asked to for the
offending counselor to do then they must
there's obviously a bar being set so
does it need to be obviously greater
more severe that's all I'm trying to get
at obviously not the exact answer
but I mean the current the current uh
fine not penalties available uh public
apology uh a removal from a senior
position like uh in the act it says you
can remove a chair uh you can be removed
from a committee things like that are
all available now I'm just wondering
where we're heading with this because
you know as I said it would be a shame
to do all this work
and then you're in a corner and yeah
it's asking lgnz to do the work rather
than us but Alex do you want to comment
because yeah I wrote this chair
um
Council pottinger actually has a point
um he absolutely has a point but it is
addressed in the local government
commission local government codes of
conduct it's recognized in that document
that
basically the issues that he's that his
his spoke spoken to so the idea here is
that
like you've said share of local
government new zealanders investigating
into this and that sets with their
resource rather than ours independently
councils are left not having to put the
bill all individually across the more
too it's um
independent from us the investigation
into it
and there's already findings that have
come out of the local government
Commission report that were scheduled to
or recommended to be implemented as part
of the future for Local Government
review however
um the report for future for local
government only comes out in July and uh
it was recommended that they should all
be bundled together but we don't know
yet the future of the future for Local
Government Review so it is recommended
that we progress this
so
comment on that point first I think that
if I look at
what the findings are of an objective
external review of behaviors
possibly his
um would have a more um
serious impact on an individual then if
we if we round the table say we don't
like what you're saying or doing or
whatever we're not necessarily seen to
be objective because we interact
personally all the time if if you're so
to speak found guilty by a jury of your
peers does that have more weight
particularly if they're a you know
really objective they don't sit around
the table with you they don't actually
see
you know your your behaviors they're not
influenced by anything else but the
reports and the interview process that's
the first thing I did want to ask Alex
just in terms of
sorry cancer Cricket uh in terms of
going forward if you've also
um
socialize this with marwata because I
think that
that it's something that I Almost sure
that they are really mindful of and
really supportive of but given the
deadlines we don't meet till next week
um
so
um that answers that question thank you
and I would just really like to thank
the young elected members Network and
the the effort that you have put behind
this personally Council Cricket to to
bring this issue forward because it's
something that you do here from other
people who work in this space I've heard
it over most of the years of my life
that I've worked for local government so
to have done this
and the thought and effort that you've
put into it I want to thank the young
elected members it's a great great
stride forward I believe if it's taken
up by us thank you so I've got Leslie
and then Alan then Ria
thank you Mr chair look I'm not going to
ask any questions I but I am going to
make a comment to me this is exactly the
sort of
um independent Nationwide process that
many of us
had hoped would have been in place
before the invercargill city council
ended up in the situation we did a few
years ago where we had two independent
appointees appointed and a quite
expensive ad hoc undertaking
um to me this is a catch before crisis
triage for those of you who are part of
the health sector you know triage does
actually
mean what it says it means if you can
catch before crisis which is what the
stream it is all about then it's a
brilliant idea there has been an
enormous amount of work go into it to
get it to the drafting it is at the
moment I have to say good on the
drafters who have who have put the work
into it because I think it's covered all
the bases
um as well as bringing in what the
commissions got in their papers which
are you know in in the sense of not
waking up waiting for that final
decision but actually taking the issue
that this the the sector needs addressed
in in Running With It
it's it's just really good to see it
here
um to get around what we know as an ad
hoc situation I mean we've had the ad
hoc situation with Tauranga who ended up
with Commissioners we ourselves ended up
with two appointees
um there are heaps of other examples
around the country where there have been
ad hoc and very expensive crisis
Solutions if LG NZ has got something
like this a well-supported remap that
actually sets up an independent
Nationwide process then I think this is
to the benefit of the sector and it's
actually one of the things we discussed
in air
um
wind up of their own situation A couple
of years ago that we could use the
learnings we had had from that to
contribute to improvements for the whole
sector and to me here is part of
actually doing that so I'm a big
supporter of this remit I would
certainly like to see invercargill city
council add our names as as one of the
supporting bodies for with the young
elective members and good on the young
elected members for picking it up as an
issue I think it's it is
look I think it's a real step in our gnz
having the chance
to really improve outcomes for our
sector and and the respect on which the
sectors held at a pretty important time
for local government to be actually
showing that we can do our own stuff a
medical Council and nursing Council have
got their own independent processes lgnz
probably should have done this years ago
it wasn't there we know it wasn't there
because to some extent we looked for it
and found it wasn't there so great okay
thank you Alan
um
I see what's
what what this would do but I also um
personally me I'm not a huge fan of the
LG NZ and I also uh
and it probably goes back to the three
Waters issue with the with the
government
um just it's just my personal View and
um I always think that the code of
conduct is set up to
to deal with these sorts of issues and
when there is an issue
um
the person who's appointed normally is a
local person so they probably often
understand the people that are involved
in a situation whereas if in a situation
if you used a sort of a body from the LG
and said which who were remote from here
they wouldn't have wouldn't have any
idea who the people involved were
and I just think that we and we would
have no control over who those people
were
I think that we already have the process
in place or the
to handle any in any issue
um
and I still think even with this here
with the situation with Tauranga and
with their recent uh
their own issues over the last six or
six or so years
um government intervention
and how would you NZ wouldn't because
it's it's a her own group you have to
think of the government sign off to to
do that so I still think they would have
been given intervention anyway so I just
don't really see the requirement for
this when we already have a process in
place that is there to handle any issues
that we may have as a council okay thank
you
um
I can't find the right ways I'm going to
try
um I understand the intent of this
rematch I totally get that I'm just not
quite comfortable with some of the areas
within it because it raises matters to
me of actually
the first issue is suitability of
candidates and local body elections what
are those guidelines there
do is there any type of restriction
around who can become a candidate apart
from the I guess if you haven't been
what was it in jail or
found of a crime for two years
um well yes there too
um so I guess for me I feel a little bit
uncomfortable
because I wonder if at the same time
we're trying to find a solution to fix a
problem around the country due to
situations that arise through different
issues within councils and in fact are
we opening up a can of worms at the same
time one of the areas is the
um loss of confidence in some areas of
local government New Zealand
can we
[Music]
um
I guess it's it's do we lose our local
ability
in terms of voice and
decision making when it comes to
complaints when more serious issues are
at hand and there's no way for us as a
council
to
to I guess remove a counselor
so I think that this is a step
in a good direction but I at the same
time don't quite think it goes far
enough
and it doesn't go far enough no so
that's what I'm saying I'm trying to
figure out how to best explain where I'm
feeling
um with this okay so we'll keep going
around so actually dance first thing
with the Pioneer
um I'll start with where I think rear
was was trying to hit if you're looking
at the suitability of candidates
completely different kettle of fish
I think the concept of it is is really
good because what you'll what we have to
do when something comes up through a
code of conduct process is get somebody
independent in to investigate it
really is here's a similar process
that is potentially much easier and
takes some of the local
responsibility away from people who
could direct things in in a way that
perhaps compromises their independence
Alex and ask a question of clarification
is it just for uh internal complaints or
is this also a process that's looking at
dealing with complaints from people
external from within local government
at this stage it's looking internal
right
um
there has been a couple of questions
raised through some wananga that we've
had about it at Young elected members
committee around whether or not the
support process
um or whether or not the process and
consideration of the investigation will
look towards CES in the relationship
between CES and mirrors because we've
seen obviously breakdowns in those over
time
um the conversation has sort of centered
around that entities like tituata in in
those part partnership sort of entities
would be also spoken to as part of that
investigation and may want to upstand
something similar to work in partnership
with with local government New Zealand
around those issues okay does that make
yep no that yeah it does that helps
tremendously
um the only caveat I'd put on there is I
think once if the idea gets support in
the remnants passed and the process goes
into place we can expect an increase in
our lgnz membership fees because the
stuff ain't going to pay for itself
unless we
from personal experience it's not cheap
um I just wanted to sort of note that
the processes that we have in place
haven't really worked for us worked for
this Council and I think what you put
forward
gives an independent
Voice or view on the on any sort of
matters that would impact on this
Council so I think before where I'm
coming from is a good thing so I think I
do want to acknowledge the wheat that's
gone on to this as well
Twitter
running it was about about the the
process following this and so do we
require when it goes to the conference
in July is that right it goes yeah do we
require a just a majority of the 67 Tas
to adopt this
okay and then what happens
when it requires because what's been
proposed so far will require changes in
the Local Government Act
probably schedule seven
so for for it to actually enact because
if you look at the code of conducts
that's featured in The Local Government
Act and that obviously needs changing
because that's the one we're working on
now
so does they have to go to a bill before
Parliament and who who instigates that
I'm assuming and I'm you know somebody
can correct me I'm assuming there's an
uptent up to close and I mean it's not
something where you're legally obliged I
don't think it's proposed to legally
obliged to go to lgnz lgnz is a members
organization doesn't it
um so you you would opt in and you would
follow that route and I guess in the
city you could up to in a particular
circumstance I think if it was up turn
up two I don't think it'd require a
change I know I totally I believe it
would require in the app because the ACT
is what gives teeth to everything we do
including a governance statement
everything Michael have you got a
comment on that yeah so
in essence this wouldn't necessarily
need a change to the Local Government
Act immediately but if you follow
through what the local government
commission and their report was saying
and some of their recommendations then
yes there would need to be changes
ultimately to the Local Government Act
but the remit is understanding what it's
seeking to set up is As um Mr chair has
indicated it's a a model that would be
able to opt and opt out but you are
quite correct councilor pottinger in
terms of sanctions available they are
what are available under the Local
Government Act unless agreed otherwise
and so just my last question is so then
if it was opt-in opt out at that level
and rather than a Local Government Act
level does the sanctions have teeth does
anything that gets uh that you opt into
does it actually have teeth if the
councils all agreed to opt into it
then potentially is potentially legally
has teeth yes but again it will depend
on what lgnz and the working body here
would be set up to follow through with
this remit comes through with and that
would be a very interesting discussion
to see in the fullness of time not a
question it's a comment I think we might
be running
ahead when we should be walking what the
remit's asking for is an investigation
into the creation of an LG NZ and
independent body it's it's suggesting
working with the local government
commission who's got a very full paper
there with a lot of meat in it
um
I agree with what Michael said about
possible changes to the act at some
stage in the future there may be a need
for something but the way this remit is
written
is not going to lead to an immediate
need to change the ACT it's going to
lead to an investigation in conjunction
with the local government commission
whose paper we're well aware of
in some work on a serious issue that
would lead to an opt and opt out yes
which has got the potential to do some
great things for the sector I think I
think running ahead to talking about
being worried about changes to the Act
and the need to put things before
Parliament is getting well down the
track of of where we're heading with
getting this remit on the floor okay I
want to take care thank you lesla once
again more questions except mine
um
Alex uh
I mean I support the thrust in this no
question I mean this work should be done
as Leslie's observed
um but we know
voting for anything other than kicking
off uh an investigation
um I do though have a couple of
questions and and I guess
they are expressing a little bit unease
although I still support the general
thrust so the first unease is that and
at least two places in this it talks
about the
um how can we remove the exposure to
defamation charged by you know someone
who raises uh a complaint
um to me that
broadens as soon as you start I don't
know if you use a word deformation but
that's what it means as soon as you
start to talk about that
um it's you really don't hold a
different ballpark because deformations
of creation which individuals have in
law which is common law think being back
a thousand years you know it's not a
it's not something that you change
lately so that was the the the first
comment I think that already is actually
some protection
um through partial privilege or
something they call it you know if it is
a formal complaint for example all right
qualified privilege right
so
um to extend that privilege to in a way
that would you know let's say lift the
risk of defamation
feels to me as all that would be the
council going too far to support that
proposal it's not quite I know what's in
here but it kind of pushes it in that
direction
that's my first point my second point is
that
um I think a rematch should be very
tightly worded
um we've already agreed to take out
Hudson
um italics on the first on the sync page
mentioning councils I think you know
inappropriate dimensional councils by
name
but I I did feel as I read it that
the same point is made several times in
several places
um and you could probably adjust this to
by half you know just by very taily
worded remitting it you know would it
would be I'm going to use about the
motive because as he would have been
places and I know it's a motive and
places because it's an emotive subject
but you know nevertheless
um
so two questions I guess I have for you
one is
um
uh I'm interested if you use the other
counselors because there's only Meats
either but whether
um you would be prepared to
um change the wording with respect to
um I'll use the word defamation I forget
if you actually use that more defamation
but
to you know so it does not appeal the
council is supporting a removal of the
possibility definition and that the
second question was really whether
you would consider working with Michael
overnight to try to get this maybe done
in here one page or one half page
document I just think it it loses impact
as you read it it kind of loses some of
its impact when you get to as you get
through it so there were I think two
questions I had for you but it doesn't
change the fact that uh support the
thrust which I think actually that he
met first four lines pretty much covers
that actually
[Music]
um I take both of your points the first
um I'll address
um in the the condensing of the words
this Rhema has been endorsed by the
young elected members committee as it
stands so we've got really minimal time
for to cut down what we've got get it
back to them get them to ratify it and
then get it across the line again it's
unfortunately time constraint so I would
have to say at this time sorry but let's
take it I'll leave it yeah
put a bit of removal of that a paragraph
which make a refer to the beginning
um
and italics where I I would not support
the gun with that because it mentions
other councils and I just think that's
inappropriate and uh yeah I'm sure I
could it
rewording of the entire thing would
probably be a bit too extensive my
second
um point to address your seeking Point
um
it
it states that I'm sorry the intent of
it is that if there is
a an issue that arises again there's a
triage system so I'm thinking on the
we're thinking on the lower level here
if there's an issue or a behavior or a
comment that arises that there is a
clearly defined map that that person can
follow to raise it and address it and in
a manner that doesn't quite escalate to
a code of conduct in the in the manner
where it escalates into a code of
conduct that's where you can get into
and the the line it says in worst case
scenario can lead to defamation
proceedings in high court now that's the
the worst case scenario that's ju that's
not saying here that we're taking any
um or removing any powers from
deformation or protection from the
information it's saying that the endow
was a process for all elected members
that if they wish to raise something to
be mediated doesn't have to escalate to
the point of defamation
so yeah okay now look I think that's
clarification Trish
sorry if I'm canceling tracker this is a
excellent piece of work
um and I really appreciate what you've
done and you probably won't take like
what I'm going to say but I'm going to
say
um I think we need to be very careful
about receiving information late I know
that there's a time pressure on
um but I think when we bring things to
the table and know that by tomorrow it's
going to be
um it's going to be has to be there and
we don't have the opportunity to reword
it or whatever if we need that we need
that it's important that we consider
that when we're doing this
I'm not discounting what you've done but
I just feel that we have to be very
careful here as counselors that we are
not put under pressure because of time
constraints can't we just clarify
yes of course just I absolutely
absolutely agree with you the this is a
risen because there's become a clear
nade and we've we've had our own issues
in the very immediate and recent
um present times this is a resonance I
guess as a collective result of the
whole network going hey we need to do
something about this so the timeline
from when all of that kicked off and the
momentum that it's gaining to raise the
standard of behavior has all been in
such quick succession and if we yeah if
we don't get it in now it kicks it to
touch for another year in which time we
lose the momentum the conversation dies
and nothing is actually done I do
appreciate that so I hope firmness is 24
hours
that we have when is the actual
24th of July so we're sitting here in
May
um but this is the LG NZ time framework
it's in their constitution yeah this is
when it has to be it's constitutional
yes and it is only an investigation yeah
actually and I guess that's the second
point to note on that is that the second
resolution there is for ICC for this
Council to endorse the remit the young
elected members have already done that
this Council does not need to if there
was disquiet about the wording uh but I
certainly pick from today's meeting that
there is a lot of encouragement around
there but I just need to raise that as
that resolution 2 is ICC also adding
their Council name to this remit okay uh
just a quick one on the actual um LG and
LG NZ conference who is our delegate
you're very welcome to as well if you
would like to because obviously we're if
we endorse it then you'll be we'll be
consumably nominate somebody to present
us
but in uh absent that
yeah yeah I'd work with Alex
can I suggest
um I'm gonna I'm gonna take it for
granted that we remove the paragraph and
italics
Alex I'm gonna take it for granted if we
do remove the paragraph in italics sure
um what's that understanding
um
I think we have to move forward and take
a leave it basis on the basis so this is
not actually a remit we are we are
simply supporting the the remote so we
don't need every single word
um we are simply you know backing them
up to the nosebleeds as it were
um so on that basis
um will somebody move number one and
number two and number two caveat by the
fact that the paragraph in
um that the offending paragraph must be
removed
should be removed there's some so
Trisha's moved it ready are you
seconding it me
um any other discussion
yes Evelyn
I'm pointing out that the remit is only
actually 50
where the rest of it is
forward the explanation so the remit
itself is actually quite succinct so
what goes externally is that the 50
words it is the whole three or four
pages uh
it's condensed and IGM pack members will
read the proposed remit and then they'll
choose to continue on into the
background should they should they wish
to they're not required so they're glued
there to to read the entire thing but
it's just to provide as much context as
to why the issues so that's fine so it's
been moved and second then with that
point of clarification
um we'll tick the vote all those in
favor say I I was against I who said I
Alan okay
yeah you won't notice that one no no
okay okay then so um the motion is
carried thank you Alex for oh you're
working
um drafting that and bringing that
forward then if it gets through the I
guess exhaustive processor lgnz will go
through to get something up then you
know it's about history I'm not work I
don't know well done okay the next paper
is the IV e m director removal and
appointment I think the removal part is
pretty straightforward doesn't it
um to Circuit the next part here I can
speak very quickly to this chair oh okay
Ivan is a shelf company which I'm the
current standing director we need a
second director we have an annual
meeting
that's it there are no director fees so
I'm going to cut across all all of that
and just suggest myself of people to be
the setting director given that I think
the only piece of
um the only piece of work is to actually
wind up the business so happy to
nominate
the councilor Campbell
named counselor is recommendation three
sounds like the included okay those in
favor
it was against
okay popular acclimation point
s
we need to because as Darren says this
is very straightforward it's what it's
it's appointing someone so we can wind
up a company we never intend to use
again it was the same person
I can seek him
is it a second
oh we have to move that it's actually
then mooned up yeah
um did somebody second thanks
um is there any further discussion those
people say aye against carried so that
takes us to the end of the
um agenda
and we will move to public excluded if
someone will move up
thank you I'll take down and and Grant
seconded
um all those in favor say aye
thank you and just before everybody goes
to
the tens of thousands of people who are
watching us avidly at home
um thank you for watching and good night
goodbye no word from our sponsor